il y a encore quelques jours le nouveau
du Lot occupait la première place dans
le classement des restaurants à Montréal
sur le site Trip Advisor il comptait 85
commentaires lui donnant tous 5 étoiles
connaissez-vous le restaurant Le nouveau
dulut à Montréal
et pourtant personne ne le connaît non
je connais pas le nouveau
coin de l'avenue du lutte et de la rue
Saint-Denis là où il devrait être situé
il n'y a pas de restaurant nommé le
nouveau du luth c'est que ce restaurant
n'existe tout simplement pas il s'agit
en fait d'un canular l'oeuvre d'un
plaisantin ce qui soulève de nombreuses
réactions j'ai trouvé ça drôle à faire
il y a plus rien qui nous surprend je
trouve ça
je fais pas vous dire que ça me fâche
peut-on se fier aux avis de
consommateurs sur Internet l'association
restauration Québec appelle à la
prudence
que ça soit totalement ou d'autres c'est
toujours important de lire aussi les
commentaires de chacun si on voit des
commentaires assez simple qui se
répètent que ce soit positif ou négatif
il se peut que ça soit pas une véritable
personne qui donc se cache derrière
cette plaisanterie
un mauvais restaurant peut être numéro 1
autant qu'un bon restaurant peut
descendre dans les rankings parce que il
y a eu des un mauvais repas mais c'était
quelqu'un qui est très actif sur
Internet on voulait un peu rire de tout
ça et je pense qu'on le démontrer
facilement que n'importe qui peut être
premier
même si il s'agit d'une blague la
gérante de ce restaurant du Vieux
Montréal nous la trouve pas très drôle
elle nous enlève une clientèle parce que
une clientèle qui aurait peut-être pu
regarder le même site puis voir exemple
qu'on a quatre étoiles ou 5 étoiles mais
il y aurait pu venir ici mais là il
s'est déplacé pour aller dans un
restaurant qui existe pas l'humoriste
Charles des chants défend sa démarche et
croient qu'il est possible d'en tirer
des leçons en retournez au bon vieux
bouche à oreille pour la restauration je
pense que ce serait une bonne chose ici
elle dit assassin Radio-Canada Montréal